this
hey this kind of stuff that's not good
what am i pulling this group and I'm not
trying to pull it off
also this pattern here is not a typical
pattern it does it cultivates you can't
use it for anything else and you're just
stuffed using the outer deltoid okay so
we want to not do that we want to not do
this and do that and you usually get
away with it because you're can't let
you they go and they're ready to take
you Kevin you see that so we don't want
to do that the next thing that we tend
to see is you pass the elbow and you
have to now go back you see that and you
just created a gift space where you will
become so again I will be here
I passed the elbow and now you go back
that's incorrect - everything goes right
into it you see that there's no going
back and I did not pull him off so watch
how I change his grip so here's the cook
you bow will show you
new projection here is that so used as a
road map you need to feel his center
okay now look at this trip
what's that look like Mitchell you see
it so if you do that hope you projection
you
oh you'll feel this Center and then
you'll start going into the pinky oh and
watch this grid do you see get a good
grip good grip can't keep it
okay you guys see that so I know
hope you pull and then start like you
were going to do this but you push
through to the elbow that takes us back
to the grip town if you're going to push
through and then peeled off no that's
the wrong pattern peel off as it is
allowing you as this being killed off
follow him you're not sinking he's
taking his grip off and that's how much
I take from him as much as he gives coke
you okay so through kids hold on and
they'll get some more realistic feedback
up right try
we're not turning about today right but
you might as well not crunch your
stomach because that's not coke you
robots try to see my my the bed for my
hips
I don't crunch my stuff okay guys how's
it you can't lift at this angle can you
see that
he has too much of a pushing vectors too
much weight on you so we have to be in
this relationship when I start to
address the grip do you understand so
you gotta get yourself in the ballpark
and some of you are like get the hand
look look at this tactically you put
this hand out of the fight he's on the
outside of you you see that you have
exposed your back but this is a no-no
your circles are not right so watch out
the first thing I do is move yes stay
there you see I did that to him I'm on
the outside now okay so don't try to
lift that hand out here even if you were
strong enough you're still not
physiologically sound outer deltoid and
you're definitely not tactically sound
so boom I'm him getting up
there now he's off to you you see now
the hem is relatively light but he still
has a grip so now I deal with the grip
ok so Bo project him o off to you here's
where I go find the DTO connect your
heart through your hip push through
don't just connect your hip line from
your hand line the hip goes through
that's what takes it all
then you deal with this hat you see now
that it's off now this is very deep some
of you dislike some of you wanted to
lift here
too early some of you want this fall
here too early
get it off you see now you take that hat
there's a sequence to everything you
must complete the Swagelok ship first
cycle book off then the hat it's just
done smoothly you can't recognize but
it's sequential II hope you pull off
hand okay when you rub that hand too
early you're asking too much of the
technique and when you ask too much you
need too much and you should not have
that kind of needed combat it won't come
to you okay go